[Musica]
sono vari geni oggi siamo sui rockets
league
venite con me allora vediamo di fare due
partite alle belle tattiche in 2d due
ragazzi sono diamante 2 difficile che io
riesca a rivara il diamante 3 è una road
to champion questa ma non arriveremo mai
a esempio perché per arrivare a champion
degli avere delle skill e che purtroppo
secondo me mi mancano e dovrei fidarmi
di più sul volo su parecchie cose però
al diamante 3 prima o poi gabriel garbo
vediamo il champion e quello che vedete
lì nel beachwear torneo stagione 1 115
ha messo contro lei champions mi sembra
che questa cosa potremmo tranquillamente
perdere lyse vado vado io vado io vado
io dò io non va nessuno perché non ho
tutto però lo capitolo dove sei compagno
fratello famiglia partire a me perché se
non quando facciamo nulla e lo dico io
ecco attirato lui geni oddio scusami
ventilata addosso però però mi volevo
ripartire non ho visto che questo
storico non ai 200 all'ora peccato che
può ripartire per bene allora va bene
metti la e mezzo netti elemento
fisicamente nel mezzo 20 e mezzo mette
in mezzo dove stai per cosa fai ti
attira bravo va bene non si è capito
niente di quello che ha fatto ma va bene
hai fatto gol quindi hai vinto tu sei
bravissima ok ok ok ok è bellissimo
bravo compagno proprio amore un compagno
decente alla prima partita ragazzi sto
morendo cioè ragazzi oggi oggi veramente
il 12 dicembre 2012 e ragazzi questa la
fine del mondo sul serio il mio compagno
sa giocare me l'ha messa in mezzo bravo
togliti garbo e mio turbo la tiro io non
è vero di latina tir up tv basta addosso
ma che squadra che sia qualche squadra
che squadra siamo ti amo io 3 a 0 in
diamante 2 contro gente di un certo
calibro non vuol dire luca quindi state
tranquilli ragazzi e ancora non è finita
ci vuole un bel 4 a 0 e deve passare
ancora un po di tempo perché si può fare
tutto in quel gioco di follia
regola numero uno di noi prima ancora
del tutorial ve lo spiego io mai dare
una partita per vinta e soprattutto dopo
il risultato così che non è per niente
rassicurato i ragazzi bisogna sempre
oddio ok
bisogna sempre dare per scontato che la
persona sia in grado di recuperare un
uomo io parlo io parlo ora si può fare
di meglio
il signor huston ragazzi che mai tenera
là in mezzo
tieni afferma va bene anche così zio
lasciami tirare lasciatemi dire mi
lasciano la porta come cristiano ronaldo
viola metto dentro zio che dovevo bravo
va in mezzo che te la butto come si
butta la pasta so perché ho detto sta
roba po manca un gol e ringrazierà
eravamo 412 possibile tira faro come
stai con il mezzo della non è vero non
tributo niente bravo zio martella perché
qui rischiamo come non so cosa bravo
bravo meno male che a ragazzi qua stiamo
soffrendo sta partita sta soffrendo
veramente senza pero tantissimo 39
secondi due gol li ho fatti anche in
dieci secondi quindi non vuol dire
niente
soprattutto se la palla rimane lì in
mezzo fermo adesso quindi vado io
mandiamo tutti e due baciare qualcuno
vada c'è il signor garbo la palla rimane
lì non sono riuscito a toglierlo stavo
tavolo farlo io ho che oggi fa scartare
fratello vai sulla palla per favore
rimane la e rimani lalique con questa
italiane eccola adesso vado a caricarla
o montino questo è un buon tiro
proprio lui piace bacca dentro a 20
secondi dalla fine che non può ancora
dire che abbiamo vinto attenzione meno
male che ogni volta che sembra che
stiano recuperando torniamo a riprende
un po di vantaggio
cosa è successo
qui puoi fare
vogliono messa dentro invece mamma mia
prova
e veramente difficile e lo si fa
scappare anche l'ultimo album favi 7 a 4
che chiude la partita
cinque gol e gli amanti e 2 confermato
ragazzi let's go my brother meno male
ritrovamento raro adesso lo apriamo
propus santo iddio che schifo e facevo
ancora nei ragazzi la partita la prima
l'abbiamo vinta quindi sono già contento
così va bene
il video ce l'abbiamo vediamo cosa
succede se prova a trovare un'altra
partita e competitivo mettimi con una
persona almeno decente dove k è pazzo
pazzo cioè era uno schizzato
va bene per favore colpisci la bravo io
veramente non posso partire così perchè
non lo fai non sa fare una partenza
cosa fa quell'altro in mezzo zio che
brutto cazzo va bene va bene va bene va
bene mi fa sognare
peccato ciao anche tutto tagli t98 lo
zio va bene vai vai vai tempo una
trombato no bravo che fosse segna pure
pensate che culo pensate che qua segnato
a caso cioè va beh va bene uno turbo
però per mandare sull'altro a tirare
così vuol tirare no
ho giocato malissimo ragazzi in difesa
adesso maledizione colpa mia potevo
evitarlo potuto evitarlo in mille modi
naxos
togli la taglia taglia taglia bravo
procchio che con l'arrivo a madonna se
non ci fossi io guardo anche se prima ho
fatto cagate stavolta bella occhio che
tira e io non posso fatto consigliati
giuro io più che toglie alta la così non
potevo fare bravate dai the moon a tre
possiamo ancora farcela picca questi
tira non alleva madonna la mancata posso
segnare
allora due o tre perché ci hanno
graziato abbiamo due minuti e 48 ragazzi
si può fare tutto la partita è aperta
praticamente se riusciamo a fare un
cacchio di gol
basta un gol ma neanche cioè perché in
realtà adesso fino alla fine abbiamo 24
di tutti e 48 mi basta giocare bene
basta giocare bene zio vai vai la bella
pro prendo io tifo fa solo riparte
sicuro tenta di ripartire mikami anche
fregato occhio bella latino no non c'è
vivo mammamia prodotti dalla importa
sarebbe stato il 3 a 3 sicuro vai frate
ti prego per bravo va bene
no alla presa bravissimo alto è tornato
che parata ha fatto gravissimo
parla ti prego si bravo come gli altri a
mano sono successe cose aspetta che
arrivo
un bellissimo non turbo frater quando
pensa con il cuore delle carte vado dirà
di non alzo madre gatto mai cosa fa il
mio compagno come gioca ma dove vai tira
santo iddio cosa fai lì cosa fa a se
avesse fermato ma si sa chi sono io ma
vuoi partire una volta decentemente di
premio non sembri st criticato mandorino
va bene va bene va bene va bene perdendo
2000 0 realizzi proviamo se proviamo se
tieni afferma peccato hanno demolito con
loro allora io io ci credo in uno minuti
area se giochiamo bene poiché questi qua
in realtà non hanno fatto niente
hanno solo sfruttato due azioni ragazzi
può fare tutto se solo riuscissimo a
sfruttarci le per bene ok basta finito
quindi ragazzi spero che visto che si sa
piace va a cagare stata la partita con
bacchettato perché che sarà potevamo
tranquillamente caffè ma si vince si
perde però che vi sia piaciuto
lasciate un commento è un mi piace ente
ancora la vittoria nas convinta spero di
portare i due vittoria prossima volta e
noi come sempre dopo che l'avrete
lasciato mi piace e dopo di iscrizione
al canale che dovete fare sudan
perché stiamo a parlare e dai è che
siamo arrivati e milioni e noi ci
vediamo come sempre la pressione della
ragazza
[Musica]
ma